- In order to try to get
as many sourdoughs as possible
identified in the world,
I am on a quest for sourdough.
For the moment, we host 107 starters
from more or less 20 countries.
And so we ended up with 17 sourdoughs
from 17 bakeries in Italy,
40, 41, 42, from Hungary,
the 64 was an old lady in China.
It's sourdoughs with a story
where I know the people there
like, 79 is from Josie
Baker in San Francisco.
104, 106, and 107 go back
to the Klondike Gold Rush.
Every library has a librarian.
Well, it happens that in
this sourdough library,
I'm the sourdough librarian.
When an idea like a
sourdough library pops up,
and you are able to do it from scratch,
well, it's my baby.
That's why I grew so much into it.
With this one I have a
very special relationship,
because it was the very first
sourdough starter we had.
This was my very first
sourdough I saw in my life,
and so I started refreshing it,
and I had to bake with it.
I immediately got interested by this dough
that I'd never seen before.
And being a baker, you
want to know more about
what's going on in there, and
then you start feeding it,
and you see it bubbling, and it's alive.
It's like a pet.
In the nineties, many people
had these little Tamagotchi,
with the little thing
that you had to feed.
Now if you killed it,
it was okay, because you could
just reset the whole thing
and start all over.
Well, here, not.
We have living sourdoughs.
They are bubbly.
Every two months, we open the jars,
and we feed the sourdough
with their original flour,
following the original recipe.
And that guarantees that
they are not changing.
The fact that we decided
to create this library,
is first of all, to
preserve its biodiversity.
If tomorrow, someone who has a sourdough
that maybe he or she
inherited from their father,
or grandmother, or whatever,
and if he or she would stop
cultivating that sourdough,
well, it's lost.
In English, we use the word "sourdough,"
but in many cultures, there
is no link to sourness.
The French ones, they say,
"pan au levain."
The Italians, they use
"lievito naturale,"
which means "natural yeast."
But the most beautiful
description for a sourdough
is the Spanish word,
"masa madre,"
which is the "mother dough."
When a daughter in the past
was going to get married,
she received a piece of
the mother dough with her
in order to feed her family.
Sourdough is back on the map.
Today, there is a revival.
Many people rediscover sourdough,
and that's the beauty.
Sourdough bread is so
much better for humankind
than just regular bread that
is fermented with yeast.
I think that every bread
has something good,
but sourdough just brings
it to another level.